48% of Americans feel moderately to very
concerned about the safety of their
money in financial institutions but
should we really be as worried as we are
not really that's thanks to three
acronyms the FDIC the SIC and wait for
it the ncu SF all of these organizations
provide insurance for depositor accounts
and member banks credit unions and
investment brokerages this means if the
institution goes under the depositors
haven't lost everything first off there
are limits for covering up to
$250,000 per individual per bank so if
you have a half a million at One bank
across different accounts technically
only half of that is covered secondly
only certain accounts qualify but it's
probably the ones you have third it does
not protect you from the loss of value
due to inflation or Market fluctuations
so just make sure everywhere you have
money is insured by one of those
institutions double check your balances
and take a deep breath most likely
you're covered